What's up guys it's Colin for theScore esports
You know csgo is built to make highlights happen
from knife kills, to one deags, to tense clutch situations,  there's a lot to choose from.
but there's perhaps nothing sexier then the AWP flick.
From AWP flicks that are nearly imperceptible
to ones so wide you wonder if the AWPer broke their wrist,
we've compiled our list of the top ten AWP flicks now before we do get into it guys
I'm going to need need you to go ahead and give that subscribe button your own flick
I know that was cringey so without further ado,
let's get into it with the top ten top flicks in CS:GO.
Kicking off our list at number ten is dennis, who shows us he can do it all,
and he's not just a pistol god. With a solo hold from quad the Swede went on an
absolute tear mowing down four Virtus.pro players to finish off the ace.
[Casting]
At number nine is this simply unforgettable clutch from FalleN,
who puts on an absolute clinic during the semifinals of IEM Katowice 2016.
With just seconds remaining in the round, FalleN single handedly keeps LG's hopes alive
with a no-scope onto Flamie before landing a disgusting flick onto Edward.
[Casting]
At number eight, we've got GuardiaN at Dreamhack Open 2015.
The now former Na'Vi player is an absolute monster as he annihilates four Titan players one after another.
File this one under just Guardian things
[Casting]
Number seven goes to hen1 at the NA qualifiers for Star Series Season 3.
Down 12-8 to Misfits, Immortals were looking for anything to get them back in the game.
Hen1 delivered. After SicK revealed his position with a flash,
the Brazilian came through with this disgusting flick through the wall,
that eventually led to a 16-14 Iimmortals comeback win.
[Casting]
At number six, we've got savage vs. kennyS at the Starseries Season 2 final
Savage went head-to-head with the French prodigy as they met down mid for a duel that ended with a filthy flick.
[Casting]
Coming in at number five is Fnatic's JW who put on a one-man show on cache,
single-handedly holding down the B site at this ESL pro league season three match.
Facing an onslaught of SK players, JW calmly picks apart the Brazilian attack with some crisp shots,
and an otherworldly VAC-worthy flick.
[Casting]
Number four is none other than the flick god himself kennyS.
Known as one of the fastest reaction shots in CS:GO history,
Kenny hits this insane flick that deletes f0rest, after the Swedish legend peeks him in apartments.
[Casting]
Coming in at number three, we've got s1mple with a flick so fast, you'll miss it if you blink.
A flick, that needs to be slowed down by up to three times, just to see.
[Casting]
Taking the runner up spot on our list, is Draken,
who, in a 1v2 against Gambit with just seconds left, baits out both mou and hobbit for a flick to remember.
This shot was so good, it left not only Castor's baffled, but teammates as well
[Casting]
Coming in at our number one spot is none other than, you guessed it, kennyS.
Kenny put on an absolute clinic, ripping apart his fellow frenchmen and former team limb from limb,
with a flick so good, he didn't even need to scope.
[Casting]
This shot was so good, even French casters were blown away.
Well guys, that's our list. And if you made it this far, you might as well drop a like, a subscribe,
and a comment, and let us know what Top 10 list you want to see next.
Thanks for watching if you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.